monster hunter rise is the next addition
in the gargantuanly popular beast
hunting series
we brave hunters have always gotten a
little help from our animal pals and in
rise we get even more
a rideable dog friend called a palomut
who has mobility in the world and some
flexibility in fights
there are tons of endemic species to
gather and each can have a huge impact
on your hunt through buffs to you and
blights to your prey
one of these new life forms called the
wire bug massively changes the way you
move and fight in the game
here's a quick overview of the new
systems in monster hunter rise
the palomood is a new companion addition
to monster hunter ryze who you can
choose to have accompany you along with
your paliko
while your palace goes gadgets support
you on hunts with buffs and debuffs the
palomute is a direct attacker in fights
but they're also rideable allowing you
to get around the map quicker than
ever without consuming stamina you can
perform attacks while mounted and just
like the palico the palamute is fully
customizable
and can wear armor the wire bug is
native to the lands around kamura
village and produces a substance called
iron silk which connects to the wire bug
and helps you get around during a hunt
you start with two wire bugs but you can
find another for a maximum of three
as you gather and prepare on your way to
a fight wire bug movement while your
weapon is sheathed is called a wire dash
with wire dash you can launch yourself
into the air suspend yourself from your
wire bug climb mountains and even wall
run until your stamina runs out or you
use another wire dash
if you get clobbered to the ground by a
monster the wire fall ability will get
you back on your feet immediately and
can then be paired with a wire dash to
quickly reposition yourself
you can attack from above by launching
into the air and attacking down onto
your prey
once you pull out your weapon iron silk
becomes deadly every one of the 14
different weapons gets
new super moves called silk bind attacks
which depending on the weapon can buff
your stats evade attacks or cause
huge damage to your prey each one has a
different wire bug charge cost and can
be swapped out so you can adjust your
hunter to your exact play style
lastly for the wire bug you can restrain
a monster with your iron silk and ride
it into battle for a short time using
the wyvern riding ability
while wyvern riding you can execute
light and heavy attacks and launch your
monster forward to smash into a wall or
another monster to do massive damage
attacking and evading will fill the
gauge for mounted punisher the monster's
ultimate ability which can then be used
on other monsters
wyvern riding can be triggered by
dealing damage with aerial and silk bind
attacks
getting monsters to fight each other in
turf wars or the easiest way
through an endemic pal called a puppet
spider which will instantly make a
monster rideable creatures that directly
help you while you're fighting like the
puppet spider are called hunting helpers
you can hold up to five of these little
guys in your helper cage and bring them
into battle to release when their
effects help you the most
they include trap bugs antedobra brew
hair
s cure go whale nard stink minks and
four different types of beetles that can
be thrown at monsters to inflict them
with debuffs called blights
the thunder beetle causes thunder blight
which allows for more stun damage to
monsters
the snow beetle causes ice blight to
slow enemies the fire beetle's fire
blight causes damage over time and
flinch while the mud beetle's water
blight softens enemy armor
other endemic life includes spira birds
who give you health
stamina attack or defense buffs until
the end of your quest
temporary buffs from creatures like the
cloth fly butter flame
peeper sex cutter fly and vigor wasp and
various plants including the jewel lily
that hides a great wire bug
monster hunter ryze is out on nintendo
switch on march 26th
i'll see you in the new rampage mode
don't miss out